so ayusha ramanchadran is associate
professor of comparative literature
professor ramachandran is a literary
critic and cultural historian of early
modern europe
her recent work focuses on europe's
relations with an expanding world and
her first book on that topic the world
makers was awarded the mla scalioni
prize in comparative literary studies
the milton society of america's shaw
cross prize for the best book chapter on
milton and the 16th century studies
association's founder's prize for the
best first book manuscript
in addition to literary and intellectual
historical questions she's interested in
early modern maps particularly world
mapping the history of science and
technology early modern empires and the
rich visual archive of illustrated books
in the period her current book project
lyric thinking humanism selfhood
modernity argues for the central
importance of lyric form and language in
shaping new intellectual possibilities
for the self in the early modern period
and beyond
christophe chuvay is assistant professor
of french because i'm going to apologize
in advance i took french for reading and
so i can't speak french so i'm going to
blunder a few of these things but um
professor chuve specializes in the
literature and culture of 17th century
france his research focuses on the book
market fashion and marketing and the
classical age the circulation of news
the making of cultural hierarchies and
cultural transfers especially between
england and france he's the author of
and here i'll read the translation only
painting the times through comedy an
introduction to mulias misanthrope and
tartuffe and co-author of three critical
editions the nouvelle nouvelle by
donaire de vis les parnas for reformer
by gabrielle guri
and a forthcoming edition of the
algorithm of louis xiv
professor chuvay is thus also active in
the field of digital humanities which
we'll hear more about today with the
mentioned critical editions multiple
databases um including the birth of
dramatic criticism in 17th century
france again i'm reading the translation
and a
book uh
interfaces what digital humanities can
do for literature please welcome
professors
oh perfect okay
take it away yeah
can we can we put away our mask i think
yeah
okay thank you all right well hello
everyone uh we're very glad to be here
aisha and i uh to talk a bit about what
is uh available to you uh in terms of
resources and help about this thing that
is terrifying thing that is called
digital humanities um there has been a
lot of debates uh
around institution on what is digital
humanities as always with any fields
there are questions of power there are a
question of resources that are that are
at play here
so there are multiple definitions of
digital humanities
and
one definition that could be
representative of what we're doing at
yale is maybe the
simplest one
the uses of computers to study
contribute to and discuss the humanities
um
so what do we mean by that uh maybe the
best one the best way to address that is
to talk a bit about our own stories and
our relationship to digital humanities
so i came to digital humanities uh
because during my phd i start using old
17th century french books that were not
available in my hometown which is
switzerland and fribourg but i wear that
was only available in paris so it was
easier for me to use google books to
access them than to go to paris every
week to check out these books right so i
started to use digital versions of books
and then i started to use plain text
search in google books to find things
that i was in it that i was interested
in and then i use library catalogs
digital library catalogs to start to
find trends is it this word a buzzword
between 1660 and 1670 for instance um
and all this kind of very everyday
application of computers to the study of
humanities
right so when i arrived in in paris i
suddenly realized that there was a whole
field
called digital humanities where
we were making graphs where we were
making trees where we were making maps
et cetera and
i both discovered how useful this kind
of representation and new approaches to
the humanities were but also
how um
they can sometimes take all the
resources and drives us away from the
actual work with humanities and with the
actual question of
which
questions we're interested in in the
humanities so this is why i wrote this
book called interfaces
which is a book that says actually it is
as much digital humanities to use a
library catalog than to
make a big data project that will
analyze topic modeling across a two
century of text right all of this is
using the the computers to change uh our
relationship and work and questions to
uh to the digital humanities because
as useful
big data is uh the transformation that
digital humanities is creating for the
humanities is a kind of everyday thing
the fact that we're accessing resources
that we are writing not using a pencil
uh but a computer is changing the way
we're working is changing the way we're
thinking it's changing the question we
are we are trying to address and this is
the approach to kind of minimal uh but
as inclusive as it can be approaches
that we uh try to
um
uh rely on here at yale
that's actually funny i didn't know
kristoff's origin story so now i do uh
and actually it's very funny because i
have a similar origin story i was
writing my dissertation trying to track
uh the appearance of the word world
across a body of texts over two
centuries and did the same thing i was
like well this was of course in the
early 2000s before the kind of huge
blowing up of big data searches and
large kinds of it's the early days of
the google engram
and i began to think wow what are the
databases of text and how do we begin to
actually begin to sort and understand
empirically if we can track these set of
thematics and concepts lexically across
multiple texts
and i did some of that work for my
dissertation and then quickly became
disillusioned with the kind of grand
possibilities it was kind of the early
days of dh still
and kind of moved away from the digital
humanities in part because i asked a
question i think many humanists ask
which is
do i really need to go to computers and
count things in order to answer
interpretive questions that are actually
at the heart of the humanities and so in
what ways is digital humanities or the
promise of databases big data
text mining spatial analysis etc really
just a kind of grand dream of making the
humanities more like the sciences as
opposed to actually asking deeper
methodological questions about what
these tools can give kind of traditional
questions in the humanities and support
kind of traditional training in the
humanities which most graduate students
actually still get today and which is
what i teach in my own classes i found
my way coming back interestingly to the
digital humanities after a long phase of
what i would call a kind of skeptical
crisis which is having used these
methods myself i sort of thought well
this is really not helpful this has just
become a thing i'm not interested in a
kind of scientism in part because my own
work is in the history of science
and then i found myself in my new
project which is about lyric poetry and
thinking about global lyric poetry on a
kind of um
you know scale that is impossible to
look at bibliographically by an
individual person to think well okay so
do computers actually have something to
tell us or help us in synthesizing
putting together and thinking
differently about the objects of our
study and one of the things that's
important here i think about this
definition which is in some ways deeply
simple but also incredibly complicated
is computers just think in two ways yes
or no 001 this is not how humanists
think so if you want to ask the computer
to do something for you or any kind of
analytical work you have to recraft the
sort of question as a humanist you were
asking
a computer to do and this is true for
super computing this is true for like
the very basic question of is this yes
or no on or off there's a kind of
powerful binary in the way in which
computers work and so to reimagine
bibliographical questions what is a poem
does this count as this kind of poem or
that kind of poem requires you to ask
really profoundly precise questions
about the object of your study which
often as humanists were not trained to
ask so i found my way back to this
project i'm working on right now which
is a census of lyric poetry for the
early modern period in a global scale
which is deeply collaborative deeply
humanistic but has also forced me in the
process of just articulating what is my
data model to ask questions about
poetics that usually people who write
about poetry don't ask
and that has produced a lot of
interesting intellectual work almost
alongside and separate from the business
of actually trying to figure out how
would i build a data model to talk about
poems and how do we
analyze large scale volumes of text to
find poems that we may not otherwise
have catalogued right so my origin story
in some ways is a story of both
fascination skepticism and then a kind
of almost reluctant return but a
reminder that digital humanities is not
just about learning a bunch of tools
which we're going to tell you about in a
moment but also about an encounter with
a different paradigm of thinking and a
paradigm of thinking that can exist
alongside and in conversation with the
ways in which humanists are
traditionally trained right and i think
yale is in some ways a great place to do
that kind of conceptual work because
we're not an institution that's uh
invested in the the fantasy of the tool
um we are an institution that is deeply
embedded in thinking philologically
thinking in comparatively thinking in
all of the kind of traditional ways in
which interpretively in which humanists
are trained so how do we take that
traditional training and think about
this new or so-called new method
and what can it do for us and i think
that this is the place with a lot of
resources for that so we thought we
would turn briefly to just talk about
some
examples of the kinds of digital human
humanities work that people are doing in
our fields and the humanities and which
are similar to yale so we'll just go
back and forth between us and start by
looking and uh christoph has kindly put
a map here this is for for my pleasure
thank you um
a lot of my work on mapping the history
of mapping in the 16th century began
actually with looking at maps online
before i actually went to the libraries
that held these books uh and there's i
mean there's a lot we can say about the
relationship between the digital
collection and the actual object and
that's a whole field of study itself
but yale because of its extraordinary
collections is a place in which the
interface of digital and
an actual object is being thought about
deeply across a number of different
collections and that is one place in
which digital humanities is powerful
alive and kind of being made every day
in our teaching and research here yeah
and i would
i would like sorry to add about that
that
as much as we can think about the
relationship between the original object
and the digital version of an object the
alternative before digital image is
where the critical edition in its wide
standardized paper so
accessing those texts those maps those
material even through a photograph that
is not a perfect replica of the original
object is already bringing in back a
materiality that was almost lost for
many many many decades before and this
is i think something that we humanists
are perfectly trained to think about and
to explore further than just saying it's
bad or it's the revolution of the world
it's more complicated than that right
um
another um kind of project that is
digital humanities is digital edition
and i think the screen here
can be used not only to replicate again
the original object but to try of new
visual and experiences a new
relationship to our object trying for
instance to rethink the very concept of
the footnote which is still very widely
used in digital editions today a
footnote and in french it's not the bad
page so it's related to the page it
doesn't make any sense anymore so how
can we think reference in a different
way in a digital world how can we bring
some sort of different reading
experience than the uh
linear one from the first start of the
book to the end of the book knowing that
often with many books we're actually not
reading them differently this is also
something that digital editions can do
on the top of making texts more
accessible uh more easily accessible
that can be
read for uh
if we need to to hear this text instead
of reading it etc etc
yep
all right um do you want to do this one
i can start and then yeah so and but so
all this is not to say that this other
most visible part of the digital
humanities that uh graphs maps trees to
to quote franco moretti's book
is not important right but i think it
should be taken into a more general
broad approach that it's another way of
looking at things the same way a digital
edition or a
photograph of material is another way of
looking at something here is another way
of looking at our text and sometimes it
doesn't answer any question that is
useful and sometimes it does answer many
questions that we need to know and that
was that were very difficult to answer
before and both are true
yeah now i just added that here looking
at these charts that one of the things
we don't talk about when we talk about
digital humanities is the question of
data literacy right and what that simply
means is what kinds of objects are data
for humanists and what is the
relationship between them and how is
that the grounds of a kind of analysis
that allows us to be critically
self-reflexive about what we are
actually doing right so having to think
about humanities objects in terms of
data and to think about what kinds of
relationships we're setting up with them
which is the kind of conceptual work of
the digital humanities that produces
things like this right uh the setting up
of a corpus the setting up of a database
these things seem deeply ordinary in a
certain way but they also require a
level of thinking that is not the same
thing as like reading a novel right it's
thinking about what do we do with that
novel when we want to create a kind of
database of characters or count certain
kinds of relationships
all right so um the other thing that's
very familiar to humanists and digital
humanities is text mining or uh sort of
the kind of corpus searching that both
christoph and i did as our origin
stories of digital humanities this is an
example from the early print lab a
project at the university of washington
at st louis
to which is a
deeply tagged corpus of
early modern texts which which can be
searched in various ways using python
and other kinds of programs to
understand relationships between texts
words and text and so on and so forth uh
this is the kind of deep textual
searching that a lot of students will
use or should think about using in their
projects
however the learning curve to get there
and the kinds of things you can do with
them is not insubstantial
maybe all right this is me again okay um
so this is actually an example of a
project that was piloted here at the
digital humanities lab at yale it's kind
of extraordinary project for image
analysis so one of the things that
is an affordance i think of the digital
humanities now is the ability to analyze
very large amounts not just of text but
also of images through the use of neural
networks
and pixplot is a tool that was built
here at the digital humanities lab um in
order to do that work to identify
analyze relationships between very large
numbers of images and this is something
that is actually used widely uh in the
sciences for various reasons i mean
particularly in like biology um to to
look at organisms and sort of shifting
molecule and chemistry for molecules and
for electron analysis its application in
the humanities is very different because
of the kinds of images and the questions
we want to ask of images right and so
pixplot is one example of the kind of
large-scale image analysis that can be
done and i will say in my own project
right now with lyric poetry i'm
exploring the possibility of we have
many many pictures of manuscript pages
and because of the shape of a poem that
is so distinctive can we use image
analysis to identify poems in
large-scale manuscript corpora that are
that are digitized into images that are
not already ocr then we can't actually
search them textually because they're in
handwriting right so in what ways do
text and image merge uh rights for us to
think differently about the nature of
our objects
and this is a point for instance where
those kind of connection and resemblance
that suddenly the computer shows us
maybe some of them are not relevant
but
this is the ability of the digital
humanities to raise question if we
decide that it's not relevant then good
not a problem but sometimes also being
able to see so much material in such a
short time space time span is also a way
to create some relationship that we
didn't see that we missed that the
critic missed until until now should we
go to the next one
um something also that is transformative
is the access to data that's the very
definition of digital humanities but the
fact that we have databases template
databases of for instance uh
performances uh in the past or uh or
contemporary performances is also a way
to access things that were
available somewhere but that would
require a tremendous amount of work to
get it together and every time the
question changed then you had to go
again to the archive and ask a different
question right and i don't think that
any mathematician would say that
computer just made things easier i think
that when you can suddenly ask question
that takes a couple of seconds to answer
versus monks to answer then you deeply
change the way you approach and work
with the humanities
so very quickly because i see you're
running out of time um another thing
that digital humanities work does is
large kind of various kinds of spatial
analysis this is the project in classics
uh it's a digital atlas of the roman
empire which is a lot of people use the
production to think about the
relationship of space and human and sort
of humanistic objects again produces
many different kinds of
spatial analysis possibilities from the
use of maps to the creation of maps to
the use of gis to map various kinds of
data onto kind of various sorts of
spatial locations
that's the kind of work that a number of
people in the humanities are
increasingly doing and that again
produce the ability to ask and answer
different kinds of questions
so this circles back to something that
we touched on
digital humanities but also humanities
as data actually what digital humanities
allows us also to think is that what we
consider as humanities is also sometimes
data that can be represented in a
different way that makes us get away
from the only textual narrative
parroting to something different
sometimes what we think is purely
humanistic is actually data and can be
better represented in form of a
different form of data maps etc than
sometimes narrated in a text so um do
you want to add something so
question
for you very more concrete what do we
have oh the e is
what resources do we have at yale that's
the technical uh issue of problems yes
so there is a many initiative at yale uh
for digital humanities people doing
digital humanities at yale as you will
find out but there are two i would say
main resource
that you should think about so the first
one is the yale dh lab that is in the
sterling library the ldh lab
offers support for any of your project
you go there during your office hours
whatever your level is how precise you
are on how unprecised you are you go
there you talk
with them about your project and they
will help they can they can offer grants
to start your project they can offer
technical support they can offer a wide
array of support and both technical and
advice and development technology etc
and please uh if you never did anything
digital go there because this is made
exactly for you if you already know how
to do it then you don't need a dsm at
some point the other one is the more um
let's say scholarly uh uh
theoretical initiative this is the uh
initiative that aisha and i are uh are
chairing so the dhikl which is trying to
build a community
around this question of the age so a
place where anyone can come and discuss
find other people who are interested in
digital humanities we have a reading
group uh the first meeting will be
november 30 if you're interested please
write to any of us to to be added to the
to the to the list
where we try to understand where is the
field where is the field going what we
can do with digital humanities find
support find project that you might be
interested to collaborate in uh and so
please join whatever your level whatever
your interests and are um we would be
happy to have you yeah and i just want
to close us out by saying that you know
uh yale yale humanities is powerful for
its connection to its collections its
long histories of training here that go
back centuries uh but it's not the
humanities at yale are not like at
stanford or mit that have been tied to
sort of
the south to tie to the development of
tools that deserve technical development
in the ways that the kind of digital
humanities labs that those institutions
have evolved over the last sort of 15
years or so
instead i think what we do here which is
very powerful and this is where the dhdl
sort of working group is a good place to
get started is to think conceptually
about how the interaction or the
interface to use kristoff's words with
computers and the humanities allows us
to think differently ask different
questions and go to the tools we need
really to answer the questions that we
that are generated by our own research
so less a kind of i would say
fetishization of the possibility of the
internet revolution and more about
thinking in powerfully new ways about
the way in which the binarism of the
computer and the complexity of the
humanities interact to create new models
of thinking research scholarship and
teaching so thanks
[Applause]
so happy to take some questions
yeah thank you for a wonderful
presentation i was curious i heard your
history of science piece in there and i
was curious how do you
track or how would we be cognizant of
when terminology can shift for things so
descriptions of conditions or ailments
or things like that
that the language around them
evolves over time so that's actually a
great question and then this is where i
think it's also an example of how
digital humanities is not about just
plugging stuff into a computer right so
i think one of the things that's really
tricky about that kind of scholarship is
you have to do a fair amount of
preliminary work to be able to know what
your search terms are
at all right and so that also means
working collaboratively and this is
something that i think humanists in
particular are not very well trained to
do in a way that scientists really are
which is to not think of yourself as the
generator of knowledge but to think of a
distributed model in which you might
have to collaboratively go to a lot of
people and be like you're a 14th century
specialist like what how was this thing
talked about in those texts and then
generate you know your own corpus of
search terminology that then you would
be able to feed into a number of
different databases to track perhaps
contextually then how that particular
word or phrase shifts but that does
require i mean this is actually crucial
it does require kind of preliminary work
before you can apply a digital technique
and so i think that often the sense of
digital humanities is you know we're
going to go and like get something
quickly and i think that actually
does that
exactly the magic magic thinking of
digitally yeah and then the truth is
like it takes a very long time to even
do things like figure out like what's my
corpus i mean i'm still spending all
this time thinking about like what is a
lyric poem in a bunch of different
traditions like even that that
terminological question but also the
like what is how do we define the object
in a way that the computer can
understand right and that binary
thinking is a huge conceptual challenge
right like that is the big work in some
ways the small work is the actual stuff
of plugging it in and like hitting a
button right
all right thank you so much this is a
wonderful presentation so i just have a
so i've been um
administrative and i've had uh i've been
videos as loud and they're really really
supportive
but one of the reasons that um
i guess i've not been able to use it to
the extent that i think i can or
shouldn't despite the fact that i've
been in my benefit my project is because
of the technical skills
yes
i feel um like if you're not bill rankin
and if it doesn't come sort of uh if you
happen to the training for it it's a
very
specific skills that's it so
just moving forward are there ways in
which we can
provide students
so i mean
i will just i mean i will just say one
thing i think that what you're putting
your finger on is a larger pedagogical
and curricular issue in doctoral
training um and i i will say that one of
the aspects of the doctoral report that
was published last year by the working
group for the graduate school was that
departments need to think about other
pathways to build in pathways into
doctoral programs precisely to recognize
things like if you have to learn python
learning python is like learning latin
in a certain way right and so can we for
instance find ways within doctoral
training to create time for students to
get the skills they might need to do the
scholarship that they want to do and so
that's a that is a hugely important and
big question in the long term i think
there's a lot of conversation about how
to do that in different departments you
should talk to your own advisor in ggs
about ways that you can actually use
that to meet requirements in your
program because departments are becoming
flexible about this the shorter term
answer i'm going to leave that to
christoph who has acquired many of these
skills
i agree and that's a general discussion
even in the humanities beyond yale right
we try to i mean also the question of
recognition one thing that i think is
interesting in what you're saying is
there should be a way to do digital
humanities with not a lot of uh
technical skills uh and this is i think
where for instance something like the
dhl the ldh lab can help
but what i mean beyond that is that
the conceptual work
should bring
questions that then someone who is
specialized can answer and digital
humanities shouldn't be at least this is
what we believe necessarily tech tacky
it's great of course it's fantastic it
allows us to think differently it allows
to do a lot of things but there should
be a way to do digital humanities
without uh uh the technical
skills necessarily uh this is also some
kind of support that we're so so there
would be two paths there is the path
where you do the conceptual work and you
you leave the technical work to to
someone who is an expert or uh
you put the work in
in learning it with all that
with all the works i guess we might
disagree on this a little bit because i
think i mean my own feeling and this has
come out of my own experience is you
need to be conversant at least a little
bit with some level of like coding and
other things because otherwise you kind
of don't know what your collaborator who
is the technical expert is doing right
like that's also so i think
collaboration absolutely is is key and
like we as humanists have to think
differently about models of creating and
doing scholarship but on the other hand
i also think that there isn't
you know there's no cop-out to
understanding basically how a database
works like i mean like that's actually a
complicated thing and like one of the
things i would like to see in humanities
training is that we offer classes for
students who actually like get their
feet wet because in college they didn't
study statistics or whatever like you
gotta need to know that stuff
right so no i i completely agree it's
about not making it frightening but
anything that we can acquire and it also
helped to rethink a lot of things in the
humanities
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you